what other projects now outside of
social networking are taking advantage
of this Apache Kafka and confluent
offering yeah you know it's it's
everywhere so it would show up in you
know ride-sharing like like lyft and
uber it would show up in big retailers
what are they doing it like the
ride-sharing they have to track GPS
locations you know it's zillions of
locations of all the all the drivers in
real time in real time it's calculating
supply and demand so they can set the
prices it's you know help you get it all
the data to match you to the right the
right pickup if there are a million
drivers on the road right now what would
that mean in terms of data points coming
in yeah it's and how often is it sending
the Jaypee Association every two days
it's amazing if you if you look at the
large users of these data systems now
they have literally like trillions of
messages a J that go trillions yeah you
know globally distributed around the
world so the use of data inside
companies sisters changed so much in the
last ten years it's amazing and how do
they manage it on a global basis do they
have to make it into pockets and
clusters of databases because yeah you
start looking at like the number of
rides in China then you look at well
there's ten cities with over 30 million
people in the number each of those is
the equivalent of maybe the whole
ride-sharing footprint here in America
so how do you do these databases all
wind up connecting or it's actually a
huge problem that's you know that's
what's motivating about what motivated
this next round of data systems and it's
you know the days of having one database
on one server somewhere rebuilding it
data center starting it yeah that's over
these are now these distributed systems
are around the world and so you know one
of the things we provide as a company is
a hosted service so you can just you
know this problem of how do we get
clusters up all around the world and
globally connect them at something yeah
you know we kind of do for you which is
an immensely hard technical problem
racking those servers would be virtuous
you know even we provide our our cloud
service in AWS so you know under all the
layers there's somebody racking servers
but that's it yeah you can get kind of
at the click of a button you have a
cloud service offering yeah and if you
were to strip it all the way you're
renting server space at AWS
yeah that's right that's right on top of
it yeah we're
providing this kind of data system as a
service so you can just get it instead
of having to set it up and run it
yourself